we've got an update on god of war
ragnarok a report on sony planning
in-game ads and more
god of war ragnarok's corey barlog has
provided an update on the upcoming
playstation game and said quote we
haven't said a lot about this that's
because everybody is heads down hard at
work we are perfectionists everyone is
tightening up graphics there is just so
much going on right now that i wish i
could share with you but it's just not
ready to be shown today april 20th is
the fourth anniversary of 2018's god of
war the game sold more than 19.5 million
copies and that was before it launched
on steam so the figure could have
climbed well above 20 million by now now
that may have been the tiniest of
updates but i'm super happy to hear that
the silence isn't a bad thing and it
just means that the team is hard at work
take as much time as you need over there
okay just don't put ads in the game i
say this because sony has begun working
on a plan to place ads inside of
playstation games through a software
developer program according to a new
report sources speaking to bloomberg
claimed that sony began working on the
project 18 months ago and is currently
doing testing with ad tech partners on
ways to help game developers place
in-game advertisements in their titles
with a particular emphasis on using them
in free-to-play games sony's plan is
similar to the one microsoft has
reportedly begun development on which is
also working on methods to insert ads
into xbox games if all goes according to
plan sony will reportedly launch its new
effort by the end of 2022 and sell
advertising space for its own
playstation games through a private
marketplace the goal of the project is
for ads to look like they've been
organically inserted into a game much
like a digital billboard in a sports
stadium such content could include
watching ads and promotions to earn
in-game items like avatar skins sony is
reportedly also being strict about which
ad tech companies can qualify for its
program as it wants to avoid firms that
collect personal information from
players are you worried about sony and
microsoft's ad plans and if so what
worries you the most let me know in
other playstation news the company
released a new app on pc for updating
the dual sense controller available on
computers running windows 10 or 11 the
firmware update program is available
through playstation's website and allows
for the dual sense control to be updated
by connecting it with a usbc cable the
dual sense controller has been
compatible with pcs since it first
released in 2020 alongside the
playstation 5 console with the device
finding an audience on pc thanks to its
haptic feedback features and several
first party playstation games being
ported over and now we just need a way
to do it wirelessly because this thing
has been nagging me to update it for a
while now and i just can't be bothered
to plug it in i have a different way to
charge it and while we're on the subject
of updates let's talk about a new one
for call of duty war zone raven software
has released a new update to resolve an
issue with battle pass progression in
war zone season 2. additionally raven
software announced warzone players will
get properly compensated if they log in
before season 2 ends according to the
patch notes an issue has been corrected
that affected battle pass gains for some
war zone players the affected players
will be retroactively awarded xp for
prior matches played but in order to
receive the xp players must log into
warzone before season 2 ends on april
27th to further appease the community
the developer also announced that all
players who log in during season 2 will
receive two one hour double battle pass
xp tokens these tokens will be good to
use either during season 2 or for future
seasons as season 2 comes to a close we
already have plenty of hints for season
3 of war zone including a new point of
interest and teases that suggest
godzilla and other iconic monsters are
coming to the island just yesterday
another monster tease was released and
at this point i feel like there's no way
this isn't godzilla season 3 is set to
start on april 27th and usually happens
around 9 00 am pacific time 12 p.m
eastern so swing by to see what happens
now hit the comment section and let me
know if you can beat godzilla in
hand-to-hand combat follow me on social
media at devonta chisholm and i'll see
you tomorrow
you